welcome back before we say goodbye we
play a quick round of truth or dare
that's right you get to ask me anything
or dare me to do anything and today we
have gia zampella
[Applause]
thank you so much for being here gia
thank you i flew in from l.a last night
i think you're familiar i am
are you kidding with this valley girl
accent yes
um gia drew the dare
drew
okay
who was the last person you were like
stalking creeping on social
and did you find anything good
[Music]
come on drew
all right i i'm on a dating app and all
the men are really quippy and coy they
won't tell you who they are or what they
do and all their instagram accounts are
private so yes sometimes i google their
name
um i i do a little like and then i'm
like oh finally i found the name and i
just am trying to figure out who they
are
and usually i resent them by the time i
figured out who they are that they made
it this hard
um but yeah i totally google guys on my
dating app because i can't figure out
who they are on the dating app
um nice
and um
recently um one guy i found out was
owned a bakery another one was a
meditator another one was a finance guy
um
and i will tell you this and don't feel
sorry for me because it's just what
happens to all of us women out there
no one has connected with me it makes
you feel like such a loser and then
you're like you know what it's just hard
out there it's hard at that for
everybody
it's hard in person it's hard on dating
apps it's vulnerable but you keep trying
and you fill your life up with so much
that it becomes secondary i don't think
my happiness is on this dating app i
think a cherry on top to my life at some
convenient cool inspiring unexpected
time might be in there
but it's that's all it is um so does
that answer a question gia i think it
does i'm manifesting somebody for you so
it's going to happen
i
when you want it when you want it i am
desperate in plenty of areas in my life
and dating isn't one of them i love that
isn't that so refreshing
thank you for this appreciation
all right that's all the time we have
thank you so much for choosing to spend
your time with us thank you
we make this show for you so take it
with you
[Music]